[Music]  and then water came angels of death  beauteous and cruel  by the pale hands many men perished  [Music]  found them in the sick of it oh come on  little sis we think we don't know what's  out there  you didn't even that woman Hydra she's a  tiger isn't she we have no Queen I'm  sorry I'm your queen what is she hiding  you don't know how dangerous your  questions are what does it mean to  summon the goddess of the water she's  not one of us why are you here this is  where I belong I'm not gonna let her  take that away from me  are you cursed by God do I look cursed  to you you know the old stories men hear  this song  [Applause]  and then they drown in their arms it  feels how  [Music]  you  [Music]  you